ansonsten
fragt sich die Nationen zwischen jede
Woche wann ist es endlich soweit wann
kommt die Wagenknecht Partei ja von Fans
und Medien herbeigesehnt wie der Messias
denn nur Sarah kann uns retten und die
AFD für immer besiegen
allein mit der Macht ihrer Worte und der
strenge ihres Gouvernanten Blicks oder
so ähnlich es ist wirklich hoch
interessant welche Hoffnung inzwischen
in diese Frau rein projiziert werden
also außer bei der Linkspartei natürlich
für die jetzt zu Ende muss man so hart
sagen ja
hier aktuelle Umfrage jeder fünfte
Wahlberechtigte könnte sich vorstellen
eine Wagenknecht Partei zu wählen im
Osten sind es sogar
29% und das kein Wunder denn wenn man
seinen Fernseher anmacht ist sie ja
meist schon da Sarah Wagenknecht ist
heute bei uns zu Gast Sahra Wagenknecht
von der links Partei Sarah Wagenknecht
Knecht Sarah Wagenknecht Sahra
Wagenknecht herzlich willkommen Sahra
Wagenknecht
Sahra Wagenknecht beim Kollegen Lanz
quasi in die Studiodeko reingewachsen
inzwischen das sitzt sie dann 18 mal
drauf stets aufrecht und belehrt uns
über die wahre Weltlage der deutsche
wird ja generell gerne belehrt ihr
neuester Vorschlag deutsches Geld für
die Ukraine nur noch wenn die Ukraine
endlich kapitulieren
Friedensverhandlungen zustimmen so
Putin gefällt das ihre Politik nennt sie
selber links konservativ also ja
sozialpolitisch irgendwie links und
gesellschaftlich ja gar nicht so könnte
man vielleicht
allerdings hat sie kaum noch konkrete
Ideen zu sozialen Themen es geht mehr so
allgemein gegen die abgehobenen
großstädtischen Eliten mit der initialen
linken hat Wagenknecht jedenfalls gar
nichts mehr Mut da ist ja eigentlich nur
noch Mitglied weil
weil ich mich immer noch viel
Mitgliedern verbunden fühle aber vor
allem auch weil ich finde wenn man etwas
kaputt macht dann sollte man das nur
machen wenn man schon weiß dass man
etwas Neues aufbauen kann
ja absolut nie Schluss machen bevor man
was besseres hat das können wir doch
alle das andere ja blöd aber haben sie
das gehört sie gibt zu dass sie die
Linke kaputt machen will das ist
interessant oder ja sie will sie kaputt
machen nutzt aber weiter die Ressourcen
der Linksfraktion also wenn es Zeit ist
gerade hat sie im Bundestag wieder zwei
Abstimmungen geschwänzt wegen einer
wichtigen Buchvorstellung in Jena ich
sage Ihnen was die Wagenknecht mit der
links verteilt macht das ist
Tierquälerei
wie eine Katze die mit einem halb toten
Vogel spielt das macht man nicht der der
angeschossene linke kam säuft derweil
stehen und leiser ab Amira Mohammed Ali
und Dietmar Bartsch wollen nicht weiter
Fraktionschefs der Linken sein doch
niemand wollte stattdessen kann die
Nieren
natürlich nicht nein es wie in der
Schule wenn neue Elternvertreter gewählt
werden und alle nur so auf ihre Schuhe
gucken
noch mal was die Sarah mit ihren Wald
ehemaligen Kollegen anstellt das ist so
nicht in Ordnung ich finde es nicht okay
wirklich nicht und und nein und obwohl
linke Themen aktuell eigentlich
Konjunktur haben verliert die
Linkspartei ihren Fraktionsstatus wenn
nur zwei Abgeordnete mit ihr in den
neuen Verein wechseln wir sagen diesen
Horror hat keiner verdient
39 linke Abgeordnete in ständiger Angst
nackte Panik vor ihr der einen Frau sie
alle zu wagenknechten was bleibt ihnen
ohne Sarah Arbeitslosigkeit Drogensucht
oder noch schlimmer ein Wechsel zur SPD
kurz gesagt die Lage ist ernst sogar
Klaus Ernst eine Partei auf der Kipping
sie sind echt komplett am Bartsch
Halloween im ZDF the Walking left
bemerkte und toten Linken
es ist nicht schön meine Damen und
Herren was sie ja durch müssen
gut gut
ich habe gehört Parteien Gründen ist
richtig Arbeit und die Erfahrung lehrt
sobald was richtig Arbeit ist ist die
Sarah schnell von Wort ne siehe Hashtag
aufstehen aber so fakt ist egal ob eine
neue Partei gegründet wird oder nicht
die deutsche Linke spaltet sich einfach
gerne Tradition umso schöner wenn man
was wieder zusammenwächst Sarah ihr Mann
also der Oskar und Gerd Schröder sind
wieder Freunde haben das gelesen die
haben sich versöhnt ist das nicht schön
hier Schröder Foto Lafer Story aus der
Bravo der Blätter mal auf nach Jahren
der Eiszeit reden die beiden alten Bros
endlich wieder dafür sagt er gehört alte
Säule was macht die Doris
und Schröder so welche Doris kenne ich
nicht
meine aktuelle alte zwingt mich
Hafermilch zu saufen stell dir das mal
vor beide lachen was für ein schönes
Wiedersehen bei einem gemeinsamen Freund
in Moskau ja so aber jetzt die
eigentlich spannende Frage was ist das
Wagenknecht Erfolgsgeheimnis vor allem
Kulturkampf gegen vocista in ihrem
Bestseller die selbstgerechten schreibt
sie die Lifestyle linken von heute
würden ihre Wähler verprellen z.B durchs
Gendern genau Gendern das ewige Aufreger
Thema aktuell wird ja in Deutschland
schon wieder über gender gestritten
warum wir können es echt nicht lassen
was gibt's da noch zu reden darüber
reden wir jetzt mit Valerie Niehaus
Lehrerin und Präsidentin des Vereins
gegen die brutale Schändung der
deutschen Sprache durch den gender
Terror erstmal Glückwunsch zu dem
sachlichen vereinsnaben vielen Dank
unser Logo ist übrigens dass Jenner
Sternchen und ein weinender Goethe das
wird nämlich gern vergessen in dieser
debatterieke Deutschland ist immer noch
das Land von Goethe Schiller und Heino
also dem Heino denn sonst kommen in
meinen Weg waren Karamba Karacho ein
Whisky halt seit dieser Woche der
wichtigste Verteidiger unserer
wunderbaren Sprache
wie stehst du zum Gendern beispielsweise
es ist für mich alles man den Handel den
haben sie ins Gehirn geschissen das
oberen Wolken so wie wir am Rheinland
sagen natürlich steht da überhaupt gar
nicht so ich würde weiter von der
schwarzen haselnusslingen ich will
weiter
lustig ist das Zigeunerleben singen
also Heino ist so ein sprachwirte und er
wird weiter das Lied von der schwarzen
Haselnuss singen selbst wenn in die
sprach Stasi dafür ins Zuchthaus steckt
einen Heino beugt man nicht ja was ich
meine schwarz-braune Haselnuss egal egal
also meine ich gender ja auch nicht aber
warum macht das Thema viele so wütend
die CDU Thüringen bringt jetzt ein
korrektes sprachige Gesetz in den
Landtag ein genderverbot für Schulen und
Verwaltung wohl wieder unterstützt von
der Überraschung AFD Entschuldigung also
in Deutschland gelten immer noch die
Regeln des Rats für deutsche
Rechtschreibung bekanntlich unser
höchstes Verfassungsorgan wer irgendwas
anderes schreibt begeht einen enormen
Verstoß im Grunde wie Diebstahl oder
Mord die sind ja auch verboten nicht
selbst in Berlin und in Bremen noch
niemand will in Schulen genderzeichen
Lehren es geht doch nur darum ob einer
der sie aus eigenem Antrieb benutzt eine
schlechtere Note kriegt oder kann froh
sein wenn er keine bescheuert kriegt
aber die Prügelstrafe haben sie ja auch
abgeschafft die voten ihren warum auch
immer
ich meine zugegeben in Sachsen-Anhalt
und Schleswig-Holstein gibt es
inzwischen tatsächlich Punkt Abzug für
gendererinnen in allen anderen Ländern
aber eben nicht weil ihr beschwert euch
doch immer über Leute die erziehen oder
was verbieten wollen und jetzt wollt ihr
Gesetze die erziehen oder was verbieten
ist mir doch kein Gesetz verbieten dass
mir das verbieten verbietet also bitte
ich mir und was heißt überhaupt verboten
wir dieser gepflegte Hamburger CDU Mann
der bringt wunderbar auf den Punkt die
staatlichen Einrichtungen sollten sich
an die deutsche Grammatik halten das
heißt wenn sie es tun und das tun sie ja
häufig also Gendern würden sie es
verbieten
wird es unterbinden so unterbinden was
völlig anderes Sprache ist ein Kulturgut
das müssen wir mit Zähnen und Klauen
verteidigen schon der Übergang von
mittelhochdeutschen ins Hochdeutsche vor
700 Jahren war ein Riesenfehler so jetzt
habe ich den Faxen dicke Hefte raus
Diktat dann passt das war überhaupt
nicht angekündigt also hier aus blau
blüht der Enzian dem legendären so nett
des größten deutschen waren Heino oh nee
doch mit ihren
roten Lippen fing es an die ich nie
vergessen kann holla hier hier holla die
Holler die wo Gott sei Dank Valerie
[Applaus]
Leute ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines
Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut